she does not once ever mention that i'
never wanted to marry him and not only
that when he died she could have easily
gone and get married again she stayed a
widow yeah she stayed a
widow just imagine the people back in
the day when they would have to travel
certain distances for months or even
years what is one thing that they would
carry with them the Quran why because
they did not have it on their mobile
devices or their gadgets brothers and
sisters imagine you have a app the Quran
app which not only shows you how much
rewards you get but reminds you to read
the Quran gives you reminders download
the Quran app now and let it testify for
you on that you read it wherever you was
we look at the situation with our what's
going on now so we look at a 9y old now
and go oh my gosh but what we're saying
is that we're talking about 1400 years
ago in this country about 100 years ago
if you read William blackstone's book on
British common law girls were betru at
the age of seven in I never said it us
I'm I'm not saying I'm just trying to
prove a point that this happened 100
years ago let alone, 1400 years ago now
what we're saying is the following we
believe that for example the prophet
Muhammad piece your him we look at his
character we look at who he was cuz when
an accusation is an aspersion for
example about your father if somebody
comes to say something about your father
you hold say I know my dad and I I I
don't what you're accusing of him cannot
be true so you don't believe no no no no
no we do what we're seeing is this
aspersion that he was a pedophilic
person is not true is someone who over
no because no no no because what that
means is someone who has attraction to
miners so what we're saying is the
prophet Muhammad his first wife was 25
years older than him so if somebody has
this perversion why at the 8ye old 7y
old 8y olds we say number one we look at
his character the fact that he was
married to one woman who was 15 years
older than him in his prime when he was
25 then when she died he married he
married Aisha but just bear in mind the
the marriage contract done at the age of
six when she became an adult n now when
I say she became an adult to you a
9-year-old not just puberty there has to
be no harm because in this country it
saids 16 is the legal age however a 16y
old girl could not be ready it could
harm her so Islam doesn't put one shoe
on all it says that each girl it depends
on her age right so it doesn't say oh
you're 16 now you can go and have
intimacy no it might not you might not
be mentally sexually and physically
ready think she was okay what we're
saying is if she was
for example at the age of n bear in mind
this is 1400 years ago 1,400 years ago
so we're saying gos back then and the
lifespan back then is totally different
now one thing that I'll tell you the
following can you ever lie about
love like for example if you I don't
know have you ever been in
love when somebody's in love you cannot
lie about love you can lie about a lot
of stuff but you cannot fake love now we
look at the prophet's marriage to Aisha
and we look at the Dynamics it was if
she was coarsed if she didn't want to be
in that marriage there was certain
things that she would have shown that
would have been like hold on a second
this doesn't make sense number one she
was perpetually jealous so anytime the
prophet Muhammad PE upon Him argument s
there was a attractive woman next to him
she would have this extreme jealousy so
much saw once she smashed she made food
for the prophet and she smashed the
plate why because the prophet Muhammad
ped be upon Him obviously he was married
we believe in polygamy in Islam he
brought he didn't know he he had some
food that was made from his other wife
now Aisha broke the plate the question
I'm asking is the following sister if
there was cerion if this was something
abnormal why didn't his enemies use it
against him and say hold on a second you
say you're a prophet of God why are you
marrying a 9-year-old because she was an
adult then you need to understand for
example you're 16 yeah have you heard um
Aon Aon did you acon Aon Rafa you heard
Aon sorry it's a different generation
okay Aon Aon different generation Aon
had a track was called it was called put
the blame on me why because he went to a
club there was a I think a 11 or 12y old
girl that was fully matured yeah no I
understand what I'm saying is you can't
take a 9-year-old today and a 9-year-old
back then and equate them because the
whole dynamic the climate and the time
was so different still see this what I'm
saying you cannot take look let me tell
you something you can go to America and
you can see 12year old girls they are so
developed you will think this girl is 24
years old so what I'm saying is the
following that we look at the prophet's
character we look at his Dynamics with
Aisha how could Aisha be coerced and be
so jealous of the Prophet why did she
have that romantic relationship with him
like she was jealous they raised
together they would the prophet peace be
upon him and they would drink from the
same cup she never once ever contested
like to speak she's a young girl know
what I mean it can be like anything in
any relationship people can go by
whatever they
say okay look there is we have for
example in our Islamic Hadith literature
narrations there are so many things
Aisha talks about yeah she talks about
for example when she got angry and she
smashed the plate she talks about so
many things that happened between them
between the prophet she does not once
ever mention that I never wanted to
marry him and not only that when he died
she could have easily gone and get
married again the thing is this just
because we sorry she stayed a WID yeah
she stayed a widow not only that she she
is one of the biggest scholars in Islam
because of her young age you know had
literat we learn it from her because she
was so young in age but what I'm saying
is the following we say the prophet
waited don't forget when was the
marriage made at the age of six when was
the marriage consumated at the age of n
if the prophet Muhammad had that
inclination why did he wait 3 years for
what for her to become an adult he
waited cuz otherwise if he had the
inclination a individual who has
peripheric inclinations he doesn't say
oh how old are you six I'm going to come
back when you're nine oh how old are you
seven I'm going to come back when you're
10 why did he wait 3 years for her to
mature and become an adult that that's
that's what we expect and there is
nothing I could understand
think especially now
like Islamic so what does Islam say
about today like is that like basically
does that apply is that what you mean
yeah okay let me make it simple nowhere
in our religion system does it say that
we have to marry a 6-year-old or
9-year-old we use that model let me tell
you how you shouldn't condemn that as
the Propet no no no we don't condemn it
we we condone it how let me explain for
example the prophet marriage did the
contract at 6 he married at 9 okay good
so if I have a son didn't they do um I'm
sorry I'm not but I don't know what it
is Arabic but tying where instead of say
that again thighing instead of what's
that having sex with
her between her thigh so then no
don't I've never heard of that so yeah
so the thing is this we say in Islam
that for example um if she the age of
for example if my son if my son is 17
years old and he meets a girl who's 15
what's the legal age in this country
good I will look at the prophet's
example the fact that he waited for AA
to become an adult I would tell my son
we follow the same example you have to
wait for her to become 16 so we use the
same model nowhere in Islam does it say
you have still married her at the AG is
that not child marriage no because we
say she become an adult at the age of
nine so at the age of six when they got
married no no no okay so he in
convention conventionally in the UK when
we talk about marriage marage it means
sex well actually people have sex before
marriage okay in Islam it's different
having a marital contract and consuma
marriage is different so a contract can
be made between two individuals and then
two years later that individual can say
I changed my mind and that marriage is
broken the consummation happens when she
becomes an adult do you get it that's
why the prophet waited for her to become
an adult at the age of
N and that's why we follow the
example so if youed to have a daughter
if I had a daughter and let's say she is
for example 12 and I have a 16-year- old
boy comes and says to
mey old man okay no problem so for
example if I have a 50-year old man who
comes and asks my daughter's hand I
would go to my daughter I would go to my
daughter and ask her for example which
is this is a common question my daughter
is not going to one to marry a 50y old
man that's my daughter my and again we
we did have that inance there was a
situation where there was a 50y old guy
who married 6-y oldold again if we
believe do you believe a 50-year-old man
can marry a
16-year-old why not on on on what basis
is that wrong like for example if a
50-year-old man came and said he wants
to date you or marry you okay why okay
I'm just trying to understand isn't the
legal are legal age 16 okay so why I'm
just I'm just curious I'm trying okay on
on on on on what basis on what basis are
you saying that is not normal sorry okay
sorry sorry so 50y old yeah once a date
a 16year old is there anything wrong
with that into the ACC into the Western
World Val no there isn't really no okay
legally is it legally it's no okay so
what I'm saying is do not think that is
wrong okay then if it's morally wrong
why is the illegal age
16 so which means that if they morally
saw it wrong they would not allow it so
what I'm saying what about 18 year old
and a 50-year
old is it right right or wrong wrong but
you see some subjective all we're just
saying is the follow n and I I don't get
how Mar he can marry someone years old
no no no but what we're saying is this
sister you're looking at again you're
looking at Dynamics today for you maybe
a 50y old 50y old 53y old is an old
grumpy
man I'm telling you men back then and
how they were it's not we're looking at
the two Dynamics which is today's time
and we're comparing it back then yeah
but is should if you to put Faith in a
book should it not be a book that is for
all the time no no no but it is we
follow that example remember I told you
if my daughter's 12 and a 16year old boy
was to come and ask for a hand I in
theet case where she was and and but but
but we apply the same thing the fact
that he waited 3 years for her to become
an adult we apply that to today's time
and say my daughter will have to become
the age of 16 so that boy will have to
wait for her 4 years the prophet waited
3 years for her to become an adult he
would have to wait four years for her to
become an adult years old physically
like but again based on okay based on
what standards you're looking at the
Western world today you're looking at
today you're looking at a 9-year-old
today we're saying the the the analogy
you example you have it doesn't equate
to what's going on back then because a
lifespan is totally different a
9-year-old today in a n back then there
were boys going to war at the age of 12
13 today you got 24 year olds playing
PlayStation at home you can't you get
what I'm trying to say you can't look at
a a 16y old today and back then so but
if we go to even Christianity the
argument for example in the Book of
Numbers not even Rebecca go to the Book
of Numbers it tells you that Jesus thank
you so what I'm saying is in a nutsh
it's all right sister so in a nutshell
what I'm saying is I don't was I forgot
my point yeah so so so in what we're
seeing is that it's two different worlds
that that was and not only that what
we're saying is not a single oh that was
it in Christianity in the Book of
Numbers Jesus is the god of the Old
Testament he orders men to go and kill
woman I mean kill men woman and any girl
that has not been touched by men who's a
virgin keep them for yourself so if
we're going to reject the prophet
Muhammad based on this premise then
we'll have to reject the god of the old
test the Christianity based on that you
get I'm trying to say if we was to use
the same standards we was going to say
the prophet Muhammad cannot be a true
Prophet because he married Aisha at
night yeah yeah if we use that then
Christianity God stipulated taking
little girls for yourself you know what
I'm trying to say but believe me look
sister the prophet I'm I look I'm trust
me how you feel I know what you're
saying and I thought about yeah I before
I came to Islam I have the same concerns
how but when I looked into it sister and
I looked into Dynamics and who the
prophet was he married woman who was 70
years old
marri child you still have sexual
attraction to a young person if he did
that then why was his only wife one of
his wife was the only one that a was n
why was other wives above one was old 70
all of them were widows and divorces if
he had the inclination why was only one
of his wives and not only that why did
they have to be a wife he could have
just done what he he wanted with her cuz
he consider I'm a prophet he didn't so
which shows that his character in
question sister is not what we think he
is because we have white middle-aged men
who are pedophilia doing pedophilia and
go to these countries there is no way we
can equate that to the prophet Muhammad
because his character and who he was and
his mission that he came with and how
truthful he was we look at that we look
at his life and his marriage with Aisha
there's not a single narration that
Aisha says he coerced me he forced me
rather she was jealous she would race
with him she she would speak about good
stuff so the thing is but could that not
be because obviously she she's a young
girl you can be easily manipulated
that's that's true it could have been
but if that's the case why did it not
ever come out even when he died she
could have say you know what all this
time I stayed she stayed a widow for the
rest of died no we don't it's not an
impossibility what we're saying is don't
just all I'm saying is one thing don't
look at a 9-year-old today in a 9old
back then if you do that it's
problematic I'll be honest with you even
for me if I look at a 9-year-old I have
a daughter seven and I'm thinking of 2
years later it would be problematic but
I know a 9-year-old Aisha is not the
9-year-old today believe me it's not so
like when you mean no no please please
when you mean like not a nyear old you
like she she was like she was an ult no
no she was an ult look like I said
before you can you would have 12 year
olds 12 year olds that are fully to
something they are more developed than
so woman so I'm saying the following but
is she not under the legal
age do we not have a do you not know
that would that would still hurt the
girl like I'm not talking about yeah
yeah what I'm saying is this if that was
the case the prophet would never marry
her at night the fact that he waited 3
years means that she was sexually
mentally and physically ready to be
married at the AG n at the age of nine
but the reason saying that is because
you're looking at a 9-year-old today
that's that's where the issues Happ
they're not the same none it's fine
sister you cannot have a look you cannot
have a 9-year-old today and compare them
to a 9-year-old 1,400 years ago do you
know what 1400 years means 1400 years
how old are you 16 16 years ago you was
in here I'm talking 1400 years ago the
Dynamics are totally different totally
different let me tell you something
that's the reason why not a single
person in history ever contested the
prophet Prophet Hood because of this not
one person in history Christians Jews
Hindus never came with us you know why
cuz that was the absolute Norms of
society of marrying cuz they were adults
yeah no I get it if it's normal back
then but no no no but they were adults
it's not about normal back then they
were adults you know how you see a 16
are you 16 are you an
adult you are well you're a teenager but
but you're an adult so the thing is this
look just as we see you as a 16-year-old
adult that was the norm then would
anybody come and say oh my gosh why she
got a boyfriend people like no she's at
an illegal age the same thing applied
then if it didn't you would have mass
people speaking against it saying to the
prophet why are you marrying a child not
a single
narration but that's that's from Ab
that's yeah no I thank you do you have a
Quran can I give you one yeah don't yeah
thank you thank you very much do you
have any other questions thank you can I
thank you for your time really
appreciate it thanks for your questions
as well thank you thank you by